Початок червня. Тисячі людей вийшли на вулиці Москви і вимагали реакції на обвинувачення уряду
в корупції, яка веде до самої вершини владної вертикалі. Той, хто зібрав людей на демонстрацію, на неї не потрапив.
Олексія Навального затримала поліція, коли він вийшов з дому.Серед тих, хто прийшов на заклик
Навального, було багато молодих людей, більшість з яких ще навчаються в школі. Це представники
покоління, про яке раніше думали, що в них немає часу на політику. Кремль  прагне перехопити ініціативу, щоб довести,
що російська влада начебто розуміє занепокоєння молодих людей. Під час телешоу президент Путін
відповідав на зручні запитання ретельно відібраної аудиторії студентів.
Що ви плануєте робити після того, як підете з посади?
Я ще не вирішив, чи йду я, чи ні.
За 8 місяців до президентських виборів у Росії Путін досі офіційно не підтвердив свою участь. Але це не
зупинило добровольців підтримати кампанію Навального і вийти на вулицю на околицях Москви.
Аня, Настя та Денис. Усім їм трохи більше 20-ти років. За своє життя вони пам'ятають лише одного президента Росії - Володимира Путіна.
Оскільки поліція не дозволяє молоді поставити агітаційні стенди, роздача листівок -  це все, що їм
залишається. Всіх трьох вже заарештовували під час виступів останніми тижнями.
Я дивилася розслідування Навального про корупцію. Це надихнуло мене. Я була зла на те,
що в нашій країні всі гроші, які ми сплачуємо як податки не йдуть на будівництво доріг чи
лікарень – натомість вони потрапляють до чиєїсь кишені.
Чим ближче до виборів, тим більше люди цікавляться політикою. Ви не можете бути
аполітичними в цій ситуації, коли все так погано. 17 років при владі - це надто довго. Нам потрібні зміни.
Я думаю, це вже дійшло до кожного зараз.
Наша основна мета зараз - переконатись, що ім'я Навального потрапляє у бюлетень
для голосування і пересвідчитися, що він бере участь у виборах.
Більшу частину президентства Путіна молоді росіяни дистанціювалися від політики. Але ситуація
змінюється, і зараз, схоже, лише опозиції вдається говорити з молоддю однією мовою.